okay today I'm going to talk to you
about electric fields an electric field
is created around any electrically
charged object and if a second charged
object is inside that field a force can
be exerted on both of them so um and
that's how does something become
electrically charged in the first place
so if you get to insulating materials
and rub them together
they can become electrically charged now
how does that work let's just imagine
here I've got my pen right here and I've
got the cloth just here so when
something becomes electrically charged
it's due to two insulating materials
rubbing together and electrons being
transferred from one to another so in
this case let's just imagine electrons
have been transferred from the cloth to
the pen it's only a level X that are
transferred never-ever protons or
neutrons because the electrons are in
shells around the outside so they are
the things that are transferred so in
this particular instance because the
electrons electrons have been
transferred from the cloth to the pan
the pan is negatively charged because
electrons have a negative charge and
this cloth because it's lost electrons
this cloth remains positively charged so
that's how things become electrically
charged in the first place now in order
to draw an electric field we always
remember that field lines go from
positive to negative so what I'm going
to do first of all is just draw two of
these things in isolation so what we
need to do to draw these electric field
lines is if it's positive they are going
to go out like this from positive to
negative now notice that always the
arrows are coming out at a right angle
to to the base to their starting point
so the electric field for this one looks
like that for my negative
because the field lines always go from
positive to negative it's going to look
exactly the same but this time all I'm
going to do is I'm going to show all of
the field lines oh that wasn't very good
that one all of the field lines that
arrows are pointing at the negative
itself so that's how we draw objects
electric fields and the field lines in
isolation
now the field when we field lines are
close together that means the field is
stronger so we can see just here these
field lines are quite close together
meaning the electric field is quite
strong here so the further we get away
because these lines are much further
away now the weaker it gets so the
closer the lines are the closer sorry
the stronger the field so all I'm going
to do now is show you how to draw this
thing called a uniform field because
sometimes we'll have these two different
two different things interacting a
positive positively electrically charged
object and a negatively so let's imagine
there I've got my positively charged
object and here I've got my negatively
charged object so I'm going to show you
how to draw something called a uniform
field because if there's a if there's a
positively charged and a negatively
charged object near to each other
they're going to exert a force on each
other they're going to attract so in
order to draw a uniform field what I do
is remember the field lines always go
from positive to negative so when I'm
drawing a uniform field I need to
remember three things I should always
draw at least three of these field lines
second bit of advice they should be
parallel to each other so we don't want
one coming off at a funny angle they
should all be completely parallel to
each other and second and thirdly sorry
they should all be the same distance
apart now I haven't done this one
perfectly because this one this gap
looks slightly bigger than that one
there but they should all be evenly
spread out so when you're doing your
uniform field to show the attraction
between a positively charged object
negatively charged object three field
lines parallel and all the same distance
apart and that basically is the
underlying principles of electric fields
thank you